[Applause]
to each and every nominee good afternoon
welcome and congratulations this
luncheon is a tradition one that's grown
more special and important over the
course of three decades a luncheon that
is not only about appreciating your
accomplishments but the chance to spend
an hour or so to relax reflect and
realize what extraordinary company you
are in think about that when we take the
annual class photo more than just a
snapshot snapshot memento of today it's
a signature milestone for when it's
displayed at the academy next to the
photos of the past it will forever
connect you with the Giants of yesterday
it ensures your place in movie history
and may very well serve as an
inspiration to generation of artists to
come with your nomination you are part
of an almost century-old community which
is not just a Hollywood community or an
American community but a global one
filled with storytellers domestic and
international one that is becoming more
inclusive and diverse with each passing
day I'm so proud to be part of that and
to see all the new faces among this
year's nominees wow what a difference a
year makes
a year when the Academy grew by 683 and
new members men and women who will
inspire the next generation with the
same sense of wonder and enchantment
that first touched each of you simply
put real progress has been made progress
that I am confident will continue in the
future as we continue to bring change to
the Academy in our entire industry when
we expand our membership when we reach
out to be inclusive we set a shining
example when our storytellers tackle
issues of importance from religious
intolerance to racism to sexism when we
bring to the screen stories from around
the world we become agents of change and
when we speak out against those who try
to put up barriers we reinforce this
important truth that all artists around
the world are connected by a powerful
bond one that speaks to our creativity
and common humanity
[Applause]
today we celebrate you your work and
your achievements but each and every one
of us knows that there are some empty
chairs in this room which has made
Academy artists activists there is a
struggle globally today over artistic
freedom that feels more urgent than at
any time since the 1950s art has no
borders art has no language and doesn't
belong to a single faith know the power
of art is that it transcends all these
things and strong societies don't censor
art they celebrate it
America should always be not a barrier
but a beacon we stand up in support of
artists around the world we stand up to
those who would try and limit our
freedom of expression and we stand up
for this fundamental principle that all
creative artists around the world arctic
are connected by that unbreakable bond
and more powerful and permanent than
nationality and politics and just as our
work does not stop at borders borders
cannot be allowed to stop any of us
the Academy stands for all those things
and is what it is today thanks to all of
you and thanks in a large part to the
wisdom guidance and leadership of our
past presidents Walter marish Richard
Khan
Sid Ganis and Hawk Koch all of whom are
with us today gentlemen please stand so
we can show you our appreciation
I'd also like to introduce our 45
Academy governors who are here with us
today great turnout I want to
acknowledge your leadership in
commitment and for all your hard work
this past year will you all please stand
leading our terrific Academy staff is
our CEO Don Hudson and an amazing team
that I am very proud to be working with
we'd also like to thank our fabulous
wonderful partners at ABC particularly
Bob Iger Ben Sherwood
chanting dungey
this year we are thrilled to have
Jennifer Todd don't get that and Mike
DeLuca as producers of the Oscars show
they are prolific and personal in
command and in touch and who better to
have at the helm of our biggest show
that means two people Mike and Jen who
have their finger not only on the pulse
of Hollywood but on that of those who
love the movies and we are so excited to
have Jimmy Kimmel as Oscar hosts
to use an analogy it's like going into
the Super Bowl with Tom Brady okay um
I'm from New England and on behalf of
the Academy we promise never to send a
mean tweet about Jimmy because I know he
will do an amazing job on February 26th
after lunch Jen and Mike will take the
stage to tell you more about the show
again congratulations on your
nominations thanks for coming out today
please enjoy your lunch and each other's
company and I look forward to seeing you
again at the Oscars
[Applause]